in San Francisco and in some of the
jurisdictions in the Bay Area we have
rain control and that ends up creating a
situation where the longer a tenant
resides in a unit
the cheaper the rent becomes for the
tenant and what that means is that you
don't have that fluid nature of people
moving on to new housing allowing for
additional opportunities for a housing
to actually open up while we belong the
fact that some people will have to
transition from San Francisco because
they can't afford it
we don't talk about what happened when
the typewriter went out of fashion
because typewriting is no longer an
appropriate choice to communicate where
did all those jobs go in the typewriter
factories for instance they'd left that
people don't sit and mourn that there
are disruptors in the economy that
impact housing and we if we attempt to
try to stop it I think we will end up
creating a situation that we wish we
won't have tried to impact
there isn't a individual conspiracy that
could be explained why we have this
housing crisis
it's a multiplicity of factors and that
trying to tag quote-unquote techies with
the responsibility is ludicrous we
welcome high salaries it increases the
tax base it creates a greater degree of
wealth that's shared throughout San
Francisco so I am personally thrilled
that we have a vibrant economy a
technology sphere that is something that
the rest of the world would relish
we should not stigmatize that we should
embrace it rest assured there will be
victims and what I mean by that there
will be people who are priced out of
this community however I'm placed out of
communities that I can't afford
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now